[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
explaining the true intentions and
hidden motivations of each and every
Titan shifter in the world of attack on
Titan including Reiner bertolt Annie
Aaron's dad Grisha the beast Titan and
all the rest I will focus on why these
individuals have done all the things
that they have done including some
unspeakably evil things that caused the
deaths of many innocent people but in
the world of attack on Titan nothing is
simple and pretty much no one is purely
evil or purely good so the true
intentions and motivations of each Titan
shifter are some of the most interesting
aspects of the entire series if you want
to see more attack on Titan content on
this channel you can leave a like to let
me know and if you're new to animal
prone to subscribe and hit that
notification bell quick warning this
video will contain manga spoilers some
of the characters that we will talk
about have not yet been properly
introduced in the anime so I have no
choice but to get into the manga
material if you don't care about
spoilers that's totally cool personally
I'm one of those people who doesn't
actually mind spoilers but if you don't
like spoilers and you don't want to be
spoiled this is your warning major
colossal sized spoilers ahead let's
start things off with Aaron Eden is the
main protagonist of attack on Titan and
his entire childhood is shattered when
his home district of Chicana was
attacked by the Titans at the very
beginning of the story Aaron sees his
home town destroyed he sees thousands of
innocent people killed and he even sees
his own mother being eaten by a Titan
right in front of his eyes this
experience traumatizes the young Aaron
and he develops an immense hatred for
Titans he swears to get revenge and kill
all the Titans so that they can never
hurt anyone else again
however when he is on the verge of being
killed by a Titan head and suddenly
transforms into a Titan and no one is
more shocked about this stunning
revelation than Aaron himself the boy
who swore to do everything he can to
fight and destroy all the Titans because
of what they did to his loved ones and
to
hometown is faced with a seemingly
impossible predicament for some reason
he himself has the ability to transform
into a Titan even though he has no idea
why this creates a powerful inner
conflict within Eren and it makes for
some fascinating character development
even though he begins as a pretty
one-dimensional character someone who
was wronged by the Titans and now he
wants revenge
circumstances force Eren to realize that
the world is never as black and white as
we'd like to think now I've heard many
people criticizing Eren as a protagonist
because he is so one-dimensional at
first and because he is driven by a
single all-encompassing obsession for
revenge but as someone who lived through
the civil war in the former Yugoslavia
as a child and as someone who was a
refugee and had to flee my hometown
never to return I can definitely relate
to Eren at certain points in my life I
also felt like the world was black and
white I felt I was wronged my childhood
was stolen from me and I wanted revenge
but as I got older I realized that war
is never simple there are always
multiple sides to the story and there
are always good people and bad people on
both sides of every conflict it's never
a case of my side being completely
innocent and pure and the enemy being
utterly sinful and evil that's just not
how life works as the story goes on
Aaron continues to learn this lesson
over and over again especially as he
learns more about the world beyond the
walls and again there will be major
spoilers ahead I'm just warning you yet
again so that no one can say that I
didn't when Aaron realizes that the
people he thought were his friends and
comrades including Reiner bertolt and
Annie were the ones behind all his
suffering he finds it incomprehensible
but when he learns about the outside
world and where Reiner Bertolt and Annie
grew up when he learns that they were
raised in Marlay where they were
indoctrinated every single day to
believe that their own people the LD ins
were children of the devil and were
utterly and completely evil Eden begins
to see the other side of the story
to say that the LD ends in Marlay are
treated as second-class citizens would
be an understatement they are held in
what is akin to concentration camps and
they are abused and mistreated every
single day of their lives
the LD ins are taught that they are
inherent
evil and the only way to atone for the
sins of their ancestors is to join the
Marley warrior program and to help
exterminate
other LD ins on the island of parodies
only by doing this can the LD ins of
Marley hope to become honorary Marley
and citizens and make life more bearable
for themselves and their families as the
story progresses Aaron sees that for the
LD ins of Marley who were brainwashed
and indoctrinated for their entire lives
the LD ins on the island are the true
evildoers just as the Titans and the
Titan shifters from our lay are the
clear villains for all the LD ins on the
island and this is the reality that
Aaron ultimately has to accept there are
multiple sides to this unfortunate
conflict and each side believes that
they are the good guys and that they are
fighting for justice they believe that
they're only doing what they have to do
in order to survive faced with this
reality Aaron has to forget his
black-and-white view of the world and he
has to decide what to do next
should he attack Marley even though this
will hurt thousands of innocent victims
victims who will suffer just like he and
his friends suffered or should he just
sit back and let Marley continue to
mercilessly abuse and slaughter lVN's
until they are all dead or should he try
to work out some sort of compromise
knowing full well that this compromise
may be impossible in the long run these
are the questions that Aaron has been
struggling with in the latest arcs of
the manga and at this point we're not
exactly sure what his ultimate decision
will be however it is clear that Aaron
has vastly progressed and grown as a
character and that he is in no way a
one-dimensional protagonist not anymore
next up is Grisha Jaeger the father of
Eden Grisha grew up as an LDN inside the
Libero internment camp in Marlay he
faced repression and abuse from the
Marlana majority throughout his entire
life and his own little sister was
brutally murdered by the marlins Grisha
could not accept such cruelty and
brutality and he decided to join the LD
and restorationist movement this
movement fought to liberate the audience
on Marlay from our layin oppression and
just as the marlins taught that all LD
ins were children of the devil and that
in their past they brutally abused other
nations the restorationist stott that
the LD and Empire of the past
was benevolent and that it must be
restored basically both sides the Marlon
government and the LD and restorationist
believed in a very simplistic view of
the world we are the good guys they are
the bad guys in order for our guys to
survive we must destroy the other guys
Grisha was so committed to the LD and
restorationist that he tried to use his
own son to infiltrate the Marlon
military in order to benefit the
restorationist cause despite the fact
that his son Zeke was only a small child
Grisha put immense amount of pressure on
him asking him to play a double agent
and to work for the restorationist from
within the Malayan system Grisha was
willing to sacrifice his own son for his
beliefs and after the restorationist s--
were portrayed by Zeke and their
movement failed Grisha managed to escape
to the island of paradise with the help
of another LD and restorationist Ehren
Kruger also known as the owl Grisha
gained the power of the attack Titan
from the owl and when he started a new
life in shegaon China he named his
second son Aaron in honor of the owl
what's more he attacked the Royal
fritzsche family gained possession of
the founding Titan and then he passed on
those powers to his new son Aaron
without Aaron's consent even though
giving Aaron these Titan powers meant
significantly shortening his son's life
and putting him in grave danger Grisha
did not care because he was willing to
do anything in order to achieve his
dream of restoring the LDN empire to
greatness he proved time and time again
that he was willing to be a terrible
father that he was willing to sacrifice
his sons and himself and that he was
even willing to kill innocent people
like the children of the Fritz family
all in the name of achieving his goal to
overthrow the Marlon regime and to
restore aldia to her former glory
then we have the owl Ehren Kruger Ehren
Kruger was a prominent leader of the LD
and restorationist in Marlay when he was
young Kruger's father joined an
insurgent force that was created by
members of the Royal for its family who
stayed on the continent their plans were
discovered by Marlon public security
authorities and they were all burned
alive with their family
as a child Krueger saw his family being
burned alive through a crack in a closet
that is the day he swore to get revenge
on Marley and restore aldia he was able
to get an LD and doctor to fake his
blood test convincing the authorities
that he wasn't LDN because of this
Krueger was able to join the Marlin
public security authorities and work as
a spy for the LD and restorationist
under the name the owl in his role as a
Marlin officer he witnessed and even
actively participated in the abuse
torture and outright murder of countless
of his own fellow LD ins he went along
with all of it without ever blowing his
cover until the time finally came for
him to turn on the Marlins and pass the
attack Titan power on to Grisha
the owl Ehren Kruger is the earliest
possessor of the attacked item power
that we have been introduced to in the
series and one can only imagine how
anyone could do the things he had done
in the name of the LD and restorationist
movement I mean for so many years he
oversaw the slaughter of his own people
but he did it all in the name of one day
destroying Marlay and restoring the
greatness of the LD an empire like
Grisha
Ehren Kruger was willing to do terrible
things to achieve his ultimate goal he
believed that the ends justified the
means and he was content with playing
the long game and doing whatever it took
for his cause to gain an advantage in
the end now let's talk about Reiner
Bertolt and Annie the three members of
the 104th Training Corps who turned out
to be Titan shifters and vicious
traitors were all LD ins born in Marlay
they spent their childhood being
indoctrinated by Marlay propaganda which
tried to convince them that all LD ends
are inherently evil and that the only
way for them to atone for the sins of
their forefathers was to help Marly
destroy the LD ends on the island they
entered the Marlin warrior program which
was designed in order to recruit LD ins
would be willing to fight for marley as
Titan shifters because only LD ins can
become Titans Marlay had to compel
audience to compete with each other in
order to determine who should inherit
one of the titan powers
the reward for LD ends who passed the
warrior program and succeeded in
inheriting one of the titan shifter
powers was honorary Marlin citizenship
for themselves and their families
riders mother was LDN but his father was
male
and Reiner worked hard in the Marlon
warrior program hoping that he could
inherit one of the Titan powers and he
wanted to do this so that he and his mom
could become honorary Marlins and be
reunited with his Marley and father at
first Reiner was convinced by the Marlin
propaganda and he truly believed that if
he did everything to Marland said he
could one day earn a better life for
himself and his family
Reiner believed that their mission was
just and that the LD ins on the island
truly were Devils who deserved to die
but as he infiltrated the island and
began interacting with the people there
including Aaron Armand Marko historia
and everyone else Reiner was forced to
realize that the people in the island
were normal people just like everyone
else the brutal nature of his mission
and his genuine friendship with some of
his comrades on the island created such
a conflict within Reiner that he
developed a form of split personality
and he became mentally unstable the
truth is that all of his sacrifice for
Marley and his ability to attain
honorary Marleen status meant nothing to
his Marley and father his father still
wanted nothing to do with him just
because he was part LDN after returning
from paradise Reiner went through a
period of utter despair and depression
unable to cope with all of the terrible
things that he had done on the island
however once Aron and the aliens
attacked Lee Berio and thousands of
innocent people died in the process
Reiner regained his sense of purpose as
he came to believe that Aaron and Zeke
had to be stopped
like Reiner bertolt became a Titan
shifter through the Marlin warrior
program he travelled to paradise with
the rest of the Marlin team and used a
colossal Titan power to break through
the shegaon china district's gate
Bertolt was a quiet boy with low
self-esteem and for the majority of the
story he relied on the guidance of his
comrade Reiner Berthold also appeared to
develop romantic feelings for his other
infiltrator comrade Andy Lionheart and
he expressed great concern about Annie's
well-being after she was captured by the
aliens on the island Berthold felt great
remorse and guilt over what he and the
other warriors had to do and like Reiner
he also came to see his fellow soldiers
in the 104th Training Corps as close
friends
this means that he also realized that
Marla's propaganda about all
LD ends being children of the devil was
false and that the LD ends on the island
were just normal people some good some
bad and others somewhere in between
eventually bertolt came to the
conclusion that no one was to blame for
the terrible situation that they were in
the world was simply cruel and they all
had to do what they had to do everyone
had to die because the world was cruel
and death was inevitable Annie Lionheart
is another LDN who grew up in Marly and
Annie gained the power of the female
Titan through the Marlin warrior program
she went on the mission to retrieve the
founding Titan from parodies along with
Reiner Berthold and Marcel Galliard she
used the female Titans power to attract
pure Titans to her Titan form so that
these Titans would flood into the
shegaon chena district after Bertold
destroyed the gate during the initial
Marlin attack but unlike Reiner and
Bertold who seemed to believe Marlin
propaganda at first until traumatic
experiences finally opened their eyes
and he never seemed to actually buy into
the Marlin propaganda and she also
quickly saw that there were some good
people and bad people on the island and
he saw that just like in the outside
world the world on the island had both
kindness and corruption both darkness
and light and she never expressed any
vigorous enthusiasm for killing in the
name of Marley despite the fact that she
often act cold and disinterested Annie
grew attached to her comrades in the
104th Training Corps and she was deeply
affected when Reiner decided that they
had to kill Marko
she was also clearly hurt when she
realized that Eren Armin and Mikasa had
figured out that she was the female
Titan and had turned on her
annie was never driven by propaganda or
any type of ideological motivation she
just wanted to provide a better life for
herself and her father back in Marley
and after arriving on the island of
paradise she tried to abort the mission
and simply return to marl a multiple
times but the zealous Reiner stopped
this from happening
now let's talk about Marcel Galliard
Marcel was the fourth warrior who was
sent on the mission to retrieve the
founding title from Paradise Island an
LVN born in marl a Marcel's parents
entered him and his brother Porco into
the warrior program Marcel was strong
reliable and quick-witted he excelled in
the program and
the honor of inheriting the jaw tighten
power Marcel seems to understand that
The Warrior Program is not all that it's
cracked up to be and he is skeptical of
Marlon propaganda for example Marcel did
not want his younger brother Porco to
become a Titan shifter even though it's
supposed to be an honour for warriors
and so in order to stop Porco from
having to accept this burden Marcel
recommended Reiner to become the next
armored Titan instead of Porco even
though Porco showed himself to be more
fit for the role than Reiner thus Porco
stayed behind as Marcel went with Reiner
Annie and Berthold to Paradise Island on
the mission to bring back the founding
Titan however on their way to the walls
a mindless Titan takes the group by
surprise and is about to eat Reiner
but Marcel pushes him out of the way and
sacrifices his own life to save riders
even though Marcel doesn't really buy
into Marlin propaganda and he sees the
dark side of what Marlay is doing he
still shows himself to be a man of honor
he was committed to protecting his
brother from the burden of becoming a
Titan shifter but despite the fact that
Reiner wanted to assume the role of the
armored Titan Marcel feels guilty about
placing that burden upon him and he
ultimately sacrifices his own life to
protect Reiner now let's talk about Amir
of the 104th Training Corps the mindless
Titan who aid Marcel and nearly derailed
the entire warrior mission turns out to
be Amir the future member of the 104th
Training Corps Amir was also born as an
LVN in Marlay and she was a nameless
orphan who was forced to desperately beg
for food in the streets an Lda man
eventually took her in and named her
Amir after the legendary Amir Fritz the
first ruler of the LDN Empire eventually
a cult formed around Amir and she was
worshipped as the reincarnation of the
original Amir because she saw how happy
this made the cult members Amir played
along however when the Marlin
authorities cracked down on the cult the
man who took Amir in claimed that she
had manipulated him and she was arrested
tortured stoned in the streets and
eventually turned into a mindless Titan
and dumped on Paradise Island she roamed
the island as a mindless Titan for six
decades before she eventually ate Marcel
which turned her back into a human with
the ability to shift into the jaw
titin since she clearly doesn't look
older than 60
it seems that humans don't actually age
while in mindless Titan form inside the
walls amir lived as a thief but at one
point she overheard a conversation about
crystalens
AKA historia and this led her to join
the military even though she maintains
an air of selfishness and coldness
outwardly Amir develops a strong
attachment to her comrades in the 104th
Training Corps and especially to
historia on the surface Amir seems to be
motivated by just trying to live her
life as freely and comfortably as
possible which makes sense after
everything she had to go through in
Marlay but eventually her actions end up
being driven by her desire to help and
protect the people that she cares about
she risks her life by using the jaw
tightened power to save historia and the
other recruits from a huge group of pure
Titans at Utgard Castle later after Erin
makes contact with the smiling Titan and
uses the founding Titan power to make
the surrounding pure Titans attack
Reiner and Bertolt Amir decides to use
the jaw Titan power to help save the two
male and warriors although Reiner gives
her a chance to escape after they evaded
the pure Titans Amir declines she says
she is tired and she wants to repay her
debt because their arrival to paradise
freed her from her endless nightmare
referring to the time she spent as a
mindless Titan she knows that the two of
them Bertold and Reinert cannot go back
empty-handed
so she decides to play the goddess as
she says and act selflessly so that they
may be spared they bring her back to
Marlay where Porco Galliard
eats her and inherits the jaw Titan
power and so the outwardly self-centered
Amir turns out to be driven by
selflessness and a desire to help others
although I personally don't understand
her decision to help Reiner and Bertold
when she knows that the jaw Titan power
will be used to attack the island which
will place historia and her other
friends in direct danger but that aside
let's talk about the frits royal family
all of the nine titan powers were
originally possessed by amir fritz the
male version of history argues that Amir
made a deal with the earth devil over
eighteen hundred years ago and that this
is why the LD ins or subjects of Amir
are also referred to as the children of
the devil on the other hand
and Krueger believes that Aamir came
into contact with the source of all
living matter and in this way she
obtained her power with the powers that
she obtained she managed to create a
vast LDN Empire
the Marlins believe that this Empire was
an evil force that abused its enemies
but the LGN restorationist believed that
the Audion Empire was a progressive
force for good Aamir paid a high price
for attaining her incredible power she
could only live for another 13 years
before she died and this led to the
curse of him here since no other Titan
shifter could be more powerful than a
mere a shifter must die within 13 years
of getting the power however we have
never actually seen a shifter die from
Amir's curse yet they always passed the
power on to someone else before hand so
we aren't 100% sure what would happen if
they did die although Ehren Kruger
believes that in that case the power
would pass on to a random newborn Elvia
after Amir Fritz died the power of the
founding Titan was kept in the royal
Fritz family later renamed the Reese
family within the walls on the island of
paradise king Karl Fritz is also
referred to as the first King behind the
walls because he was the one who
relocated a portion of the audience to
Paradise Island and created the three
walls using tens of millions of colossal
Titans he is also the one who used the
power of the founding Titan to erase the
memories of those same Aldean's so that
they came to believe that they were the
last remnants of humanity and that there
was nothing beyond the walls except for
Titans in order to protect the true
royal family he renamed them from fritz
to Reese so that they could avoid all
public attention while another bloodline
played the role of the royal family
within the walls
according to Willie Tiber a hundred
years ago the LDN Empire was using the
power of the Titans to rule the world
while the royal Fritz family held the
founding Titan the other eight Titans
were held by other families who
continuously fought each other over the
remaining titan powers Willy Tiber
claims although it is important to know
that this may just be propaganda and not
actually true that Carl fritz
even before he inherited the founding
Titan power felt guilty about the LDN
empires brutal history including the
deadly wars and oppressive
that kept aldea as the most powerful
empire in the world when he inherited a
Titan power Karl Fritz conspired with
one of the Titan families the Tiber
family who possessed the Warhammer Titan
in order to put an end to the LDN Empire
Karl Fritz created the walls with the
help of tens of millions of colossal
Titans and claimed that he would unleash
the Titans inside to flatten the earth
if anyone interfered in the affairs of
the island however according to Willie
Tiber Karl Fritz didn't actually mean
this in reality he renounced war and
made sure that his pacifist philosophy
would be passed down to every royal
blooded inheritor of the founding Titan
since only those of royal blood can
unlock the full potential the founding
Titan Karl thought that this would
ensure that the founding tiny is never
used against other nations again his
ultimate goal was peace but Karl Fritz
had also accepted the fact that Marlay
might grow as a nation and eventually
exterminate all ldiots including the
royal family but he believed that the
crimes that the LD UNS committed in the
past were so grave that they should
never have existed in the first place
and could never atone for their actions
so their extermination was justified but
until the day of extermination came he
wanted to enjoy a peaceful paradise
inside the walls with his people for as
long as he could however we have to
remember that this is the story that
Willy Tiber tells everyone in Majerle
about Karl Fritz's true motivations it
may not be true it could be just a lie
designed to benefit the Tiber family and
portray them as heroes we don't know who
the other inheritors of the founding
Titan were until mr. Reis who was the
father of Yuri Reis and rod Ruiz and of
course we know that rod Ruiz is
historians father mr. Reis inherited the
first King's ideology and he refused to
put a stop to the Titan threat despite
the pleas of EURion rod to defeat the
Titans so that humanity could safely
venture outside the walls he even
appeared to have imprisoned his son rod
because of his constant attempts to
convince his father to destroy the
Titans eventually Yuri Reis rods younger
brother inherited the power of the
founding Titan Yuri was always
determined to save humanity from the
Titans before he inherited the power
however once he ate his father and
inherited the power he also inherited
car
Fritz's ideology and as a result he
refused to save humanity from the Titans
or to tell anyone about their lost
memories yuri eventually passed down his
power to his niece Freda Reis Freda Rhys
was the daughter of rod Reis and she was
also historias older half-sister at the
age of 15 she injected herself with the
Titan serum and as a mindless Titan ate
her uncle inheriting the founding Titan
like Yuri she believed that she could
fight the ideology of the first king
carl frits
she told rod and i quote leave it to me
father I won't let the ghosts of our
ancestors get the better of me but she
also immediately changed her tune after
inheriting the founding Titan power and
she also adopted Carl Fritz's ideology
but despite inheriting the memories of
the founding tightened Frieda did not
become completely cold or emotionless
she would secretly visit her younger
half-sister historia back when she lived
a lonely existence on a farm and Frieda
would read to her and tell her about
their ancestor Emir fritz it was clear
that Frieda cared deeply for historian
however Frieda would erase his story as
memories after every encounter so that
she wouldn't know anything about the
outside world just like the rest of
humanity behind the walls Frieda was
ultimately killed by Grisha who took the
founding Titan power and eventually
passed it on to Aaron because Grisha and
Aaron don't have royal blood they were
not affected by the first kings ideology
after gaining the founding Titan power
next up let's talk about pork or
Galliard
the younger brother of the former jaw
tightened holder Marcel Porco Galliard
is the current possessor of the jaw
Titan power Porco has been a loyal
soldier for the Marlon Army and we have
seen him use his jaw tightened power to
great effect in battle between male and
its enemies as another LDN who was born
in Marlay and went through the warrior
program pork was primarily driven by his
loyalty to his fellow warriors and he
shows great emotional attachment to them
and a strong desire to protect them
because of this Porco is especially
shocked at Zeke's betrayal and Porco
desperately wants revenge for what Zeke
and Aaron did in lis burial Porco is
prone to emotional outbursts that can
get the better of him and this has been
exploited by the survey corps in the
past
then we have peak peak is the only known
holder of the card titan power as we
still don't know anything about any of
the past possessors peak also inherited
her Titan power from the male and
warrior program she has demonstrated
exceptional intelligence and she was
given the cart Titan power specifically
because she showed strong judgment peak
has shown incredible skills in battle
despite the fact that her Titan doesn't
have strong offensive capabilities and
she has also shown an immense amount of
dedication to her comrades in the
warrior program peak in her cart Titan
form was the one who managed to save and
retrieve Zeek and Reinert during the
battle of Chicano Peaks intelligence
allows her to see through Marla's
propaganda and in the past she has
voiced veiled criticism of Marla's
policies towards the LD ends and to
their questionable battle strategies
peak recognizes that once modern weapons
rendered Titan powers irrelevant Marlay
and the other nations of the world will
probably try to eradicate all
ldiots as such Peaks motivation is to
find a way to save the ldm people and
end their oppression but she is
conflicted as to how to pursue those
ends she disagrees with Marla's brutal
treatment of LD ins but she also can't
support what Aaron and Zeke did to
Lipari oh and how they were willing to
sacrifice innocent civilians in order to
achieve their goals as of the making of
this video Peaks loyalties lie with her
fellow LD and warriors like Reiner Porco
Gabi and Falco but we are not sure whose
side peak will end up on at the end or
whether she will use her vast
intelligence to come up with a
completely different solution that
defies the wishes of both male and the
Yeager ists then we have the younger
sister of Willi Tiber who was the
shifter who possessed the power of the
Warhammer Titan the Titan that was
passed on within the tiber family for
generations she secretly possessed the
Warhammer Titan power while publicly the
Tiber family claimed that Willie was the
Warhammer Titan we don't know much about
what her motivations were other than the
fact that she was loyal to her family
and that she wanted to defeat Eren she
may really be loyal to Marlay or she may
have been merely protecting the
interests of the Tiber family itself
which is an LD and royal family that
receives special treatment in Marlay
because of the role they played in
bringing down the LD an empire she was
defeated and eaten by Aaron before we
even learned her first name then we have
Zeke Jager and his other quote unquote
father
savor Zeke Jaeger is the son of Grisha
Jaeger and Deena Fritz and Eren Yeager's
older half-brother he was entered into
the Marland Warrior Program by Grisha
who as we know was an LD and
restorationist and wanted to plant his
son as an LD inspire thin the Marlon
military but one day Zeek appeared to
betray his parents and rat them out
along with other LD and restorationist
s-- later in the manga we learned that
Zeke had realized that the Marlon
military was just about to take down the
LD restorationist
and Zeke decided to betray his parents
on the advice of his mentor in the
warrior program Tom's aver if he did
nothing and the Marlon Army inevitably
found out the truth on their own they
would have killed all the restorationist
along with their families including Zeke
and his grandparents the former beast
Titan Tom's a Burt old Zeke that his
parents were cruel to him for putting
him through everything they had put him
through and he specifically told him to
save himself and his grandparents by
betraying Grisha and Deena by betraying
his parents Zeke was able to save
himself and his grandparents and he was
also able to keep the fact that he had
royal blood hidden from the Marley and
military Zeke has the least amount of
time left to live out of the current
Titan shifters and for a time we were
led to believe that Zeke secretly wanted
to save the LD ends and that he and
Aaron were plotting to defeat Marley in
order to end the repression of the LD in
population however in recent chapters we
learned that Zeke apparently wants to
euthanize the entire LDN race his own
race as it appears right now Zeke has a
nihilistic philosophy which holds that
all LD ends by virtue of being able to
transform into Titans are accursed and
they will always be attacked and seen as
evil because of this ability for that
reason Zeke has come to believe that it
would be better for LD ends if they
never even existed and he wants to
ensure that this generation of LD ends
will be the final generation
he hopes to use the founding Titans
ability currently possessed by his
brother Aaron in order to make all LD
ins alive today sterile which would mean
that they cannot produce any more
offspring and the entire LD and race
would die off with this generation this
euthanasia plan was inspired by the
former beast tighten and Zeke's mentor
Tom shaver who also came to believe that
the life of an LVN was nothing but
Xavier was the one who told Zig that the
power of the founding titan allows the
holder not only to manipulate the
memories of all LD ends but also their
physical composition meaning that the
founding titan power could forcibly
sterilized all ldiots xavier also told
Zig that in order to carry out this plan
he would need to work together with
someone who holds the founding Titan but
doesn't possess royal blood because that
is the only way to stop the first Kings
ideology from taking over personally I
completely disagree with this plan and I
hope Zeke doesn't actually go through
with it and I certainly hope that Aaron
will not ultimately support Zeke and
this I understand that the other nations
are afraid of LD ends because of their
ability to turn into Titans but the
individual LD ends alive today are not
responsible for the sins of their
ancestors and they are not at fault for
the fact that they can turn into Titans
I just don't understand how anyone could
possess the amount of self-hatred
required to want to erase their own
people from the world and I am betting
that if not Zeke then at least Eren will
come to his senses and stop this insane
plan from coming to fruition and finally
we also have Armin who unwillingly
became the next colossal Titan after he
ate Bertolt from what I've seen so far
Armand's personality doesn't appear to
have changed that much after becoming
the colossal Titan although he is
definitely willing to kill a large
number of our land soldiers if that's
what he has to do to survive Armin
ultimately wants peace and he doesn't
trust people like Zeke Armin's goal is
to use his intelligence to come up with
a compromise that will allow both LD ins
and other nations of the world to
coexist peacefully anyway let me know
what you guys think who is your favorite
Titan shifter and which of their
motivations can you relate to the most
also how do you think this whole thing
will end is Zeke really going to go
through with his plan and is Eren really
going to go along with it let me know
down in the comments if you enjoyed the
attack on titan content on this channel
and you want to see more leave a like to
let me know and if you're new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell a huge thank you
to all of our anime uproar patrons for
supporting our work when I especially
thank our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh keelon and chubs is
the man and another huge thank you to
our the one to your patrons the one
who stand above all other clans
including ace Maddie Mac James L Olin
Adam
Ingrid ah and Ahmad and at the very
pinnacle of interdimensional greatness
the tier reserved only for legends a
massive thank you to baby ray the
first-ever disciple of Lord Twigg Oh
himself if you guys feel that our
content provides value for you and you
want to support more be sure to check
out our patreon link in the description
even donating a single dollar will give
you access to our anime uproar patron
exclusive discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]